okay so things are looking good we found
our upper and lower boundaries using
these um these implications about the
probability density function what's this
next question so it says hence determine
the score of the 85th percentile hmm
okay so we need to we need to think
about this for a second because we've
talked about medians for a little bit
and we've heard of percentiles before
but we haven't really talked about them
recently right so let's think about what
what is a quarrel or what is a median
for example right it is that particular
score right here that divides up your
dataset into two equal chunks right now
we weirdly describe it as q2 because the
median is also a quartile right
quartiles don't divide your scores into
two groups as the name suggests
quartiles they divide your scores into
quarters right into into four equal
groups so I mean I'm just gonna roughly
eyeball this but I would say that the
the first quartile might be somewhere
around here okay q1 might be here so you
know I have expecting that this part in
here this area would be 1/4 this area
here will also be 1/4 so that would make
q1 that spot in the middle which divides
it up and then q3 we've already got q2
q3 I'm I'm guessing will be so around
here again this is just a proximate
right so you can see I've now got other
matters will write it in for areas that
are all going to be 1/4 let's see that
so this is the way quartiles work now
reaching we can just extend this idea
write quartiles divide you into four
groups um deciles as the name suggests
Dec they divide your data set into ten
equal groups and percentiles divide your
data into a hundred equal groups so in
fact our quartiles here can be expressed
as percentiles right you know he won it
divides up the the first quarter of the
scores from the other three-quarters of
the scores right so it would be the
twenty-fifth percentile because you got
25 percent of scores
before that and then 75% or above this
guy here their median we would also call
that P 50 because um the median is above
50% of the scores and then here we would
say q3 is the 75th percentile right now
we have a common example real world
example this the 8r works very much like
this right so it is like a percentile in
that if you've got an ATAR of 99 that
positions you in relation to the other
99 percent of people who did the HSC or
did the exam when you did right so
therefore if this is the way this works
you can see the implications that this
haves for the integrals right if we want
to find where the 85th percentile is the
85th percentile like I don't know in
this one if if this guy here is the 75th
percentile the 85th percentile I'm
actually going to go and put it on to
this graph here because this is the
actual probability density function I'm
dealing with and the 85th percentile
should be that point such that 85% of
the scores are below it right so I mean
I'm guessing it'll be somewhere around
here right p85 should be somewhere
around there because this section here
looks like it's roughly 85% of the
scores so the probability of selecting
one of the scores at random would be 85%
so now that I know what a percentile is
and its implication for area I can now
set out an integral that'll help me
solve this right do I know this base
here yeah I reckon let's let's put it
right under here okay so question two
how am I going to word this well P 85 is
the score such that I should write this
down is the score and that is above 85%
of the scores are owned or equal to so
what I can do is I can say therefore
from the lower boundary which I know to
be root 5 all the way up until P 85 this
is that black shaded area that I was
trying to get out here let's little bit
crosshatch don't be more obvious right
that should be the 85% of scores so you
can see I'm forming integral from root 5
which is my
Banri all the way up to p 85 whatever
that happens to be so let's go ahead and
form the rest of this integral here
right so it's x on for DX and that
should be equal to 85 over 100 that's
the 85% okay
and what I'm gonna do here is I'm gonna
evaluate this just like I found the
lower and upper boundaries right this
right hand side it still integrates 2x
squared on 8 but I've got new boundaries
here root 5 and P 85 the right hand side
there 85 on 100 common factor of 5 so
you're gonna get 17 on 20 if you were to
cancel that common factor now what are
we gonna get here it'll look a bit messy
for a little bit but I can still work
with it I'm gonna substitute in my upper
and lower boundaries so here comes the
85th percentile squared divided by 8 and
then I'm gonna subtract the lower
boundary squared so that's root 5
squared which is 5 divided by 8 equals
17 on 20 and so now what I want to do is
just make p85 the 85th percentile make
that the subject and then off I go okay
you're probably getting a bit of the
rhythm here I want to get rid of
fractions so I want the lowest common
multiple of 8 and 20 which is 40 okay so
I'm going to multiply everything by 40
which gives me 5 lots here take away 5
lots of 5 which is 25 and then on the
right hand side if I multiply both sides
by 40 40 and 20 will cancel out giving
me 2 lots of 17 on the top like so I've
got 5 lots of p85 on the left-hand side
which I want to isolate I add 25 to both
sides that gives me 59 and then I'll
divide on both sides by 5 which gives me
whatever this number happens to be this
is hopefully starting to look familiar
because this is what we had to do with
the lower and the upper bounds I will
take the square root noticing that I
have both of them but I will notice that
my x-values have to be greater than or
equal to 0 and the 85th percentile is
one of the x-values so I could have even
said if I wanted to you know
my point even more strongly that X has
got to be greater than or equal to root
5 but it's sufficient like all I'm
trying to do is get rid of a negative
answer so this is sufficient to be able
to say that
so therefore p85 is equal to the square
root of 59 on 5 whatever that value is
now thankfully I've already gone and I
fiddled with this so this graph that you
saw before I still have it in desmos
here and you can see what I've done is
I've gone ahead and worked out what that
square root of 59 on five is it's about
three point four three five and so if
you put that line in there that guy
there that is the 85th percentile and
hopefully when you have a look at that
it's not bad in terms of what i
eyeballed before the 85th percentile is
pretty high up I could have worked out
what the 85th percentile was by also
looking at the upper bound um I could
have said that there's 15% of the scores
above this just as much as I could have
said there are 85 percent of scores
below it but hopefully that makes sense
and you can see how I can use this
information about the probability
density function to find out any
percentile or quartile or median that I
like